you love it
you need it you wanted it you asked for
it here it is
locked in sewer the update I actually
have made uh it much better because
not only freeze foxy freeze fresh body
not only have they updated the game
what is it not an option they updated
the game and they removed the head
bobbing and they made out their
their slider it has all the updates that
you could possibly want bug fixes
that's it so now we can enjoy locked in
sewer and I can only assume that there's
some true ending on hard mode
and you oh look
look at that still a little shimmy on
the head that's way better that's way
better all right
so we're back in it and I was eagerly
awaiting getting back into this game and
I know you guys were too which is why
I'm very happy to see what's going on
with uh this adventure and why Bonnie
and uh foxy are trapped in the sewer and
maybe Freddy I'm not 100 sure but I
think I think they're all here
all right
time to get to work all we need are 16.
16 sweet delightful little valves and we
are in our freedom I don't even know if
there are 16 total vows it might just be
that there are 16
that I need to do
let us say all the valves so
okay
wait which way is he oh no
no way he's coming the way that I'm
going right good stuff good stuff
oh I close that one
okay
we're already doing better than I did
before okay
that's six valves and I gotta imagine
that at some point
wait
that's bad
oh wait a minute oh wait a minute
[Music]
Alexian uh roll it back uh let's act
like the video just started and then I
didn't die a horribly embarrassing death
and that everything is good okay cool
you wanted it you needed it
I'm here to provide more of it it's
locked in somewhere yes I know hold your
applause it is time for one of my
favorite Five Nights at Freddy's fan
games that I played in a very long time
that the developer updated to not only
be better and fix bugs but also to make
it easier to see and easier to move yes
the head bobbing has been reduced and
therefore I can play this game it was
the only thing holding me back from
playing this game to its fullest and I
I'm just so excited to say I'm glad to
be back in the midst of this this is
going to be a real fun time
you didn't see anything ah perfect over
here great
well that's probably a problem
this will be fine maybe I should get the
ones close to Bonnie because Bonnie's
gonna spawn I bet at us I think he did
actually
probably be a good idea no
he's not the first official route
all right let's see let's roll it back
uh let's roll it back let's roll it back
you begged for it you quaked for it you
never knew that you were gonna get it
but here it is today's the day look Ed
it's sewer has been updated it's been
updated with not only better mechanics
not only better graphics not only better
performance not only bug fixes but also
it's now more playable than ever because
the head bobbing has been reduced so I'm
finally going to be able to tackle this
game with every ounce of my Hotspot and
I'm gonna do it perfectly for you guys
because I've been waiting I've been
itching my entire network of people that
inform me of all the best games to play
were just banging down my door to give
me these insights in what is going to be
the next hot Five Nights at Freddy's fan
game which is this one locked into her
which is why that I'm more
I'm I'm
more than happy than ever to be able to
play it for you here today and beat it
because that's what I'm all about here
at Markiplier HQ
of which I run a team of maybe in the
hundreds of people we are all working
together in coordinated action to be
able to give you the very best of
entertainment
foreign
[Music]
you stopped for it you wept for it you
begged on your knees for an update to
this game that I'm about to reveal to
you but do you deserve it do you even
think that you deserve it because if you
ask yourself and you look inside your
soul you'll know that you do not how
could you how could you deserve what is
about to come for you and yet I am
generous I
can provide Lexi put a little like
darker glitch there just a little bit a
little taste of that this is where
they're going to notice finally I've
been waiting for someone to notice this
for so long is that my background is
part red and then part blue no one's
even noticed it they're so stupid it's
naturally built in chromatic aberration
everyone was really dumb dark Blair has
been here all the time anyway
um wait right I gotta get back into the
bit
it's locked in sewer been an update to
the game better graphics
bug fixes I just sprayed chewed up food
on my mind oh I'm smearing it uh anyway
look at this
that's all I need to say about that
I don't need to say anything else it
speaks for itself
it really does so with that being said
it's time to dig deep get down
and get detected and then find that
wrench and get these repairs underway
nothing's gonna stop me from clinching
that oh so sweet victory I know he's
going to come this way now welp
no okay
well this seems highly improbable
oh boy
wow he's an idiot he doesn't even know
too blind to see
oh he sees me he's not that blind
this is what it's all about
I'm about to show you
the immense amount of training that I've
put myself through
to be able to perform at the highest
level of Five Nights at Freddy's
gameplay just for you and that's what
I'm gonna do I intend to deliver on
every promise that I have ever
experienced for you
and I have promised so much
and unlike someone else
I deliver
I don't know who I'm referring to but
you know who I'm referring to okay four
valves
I should probably get the valve near
Bonnie oh that's a problem
not as much of a problem as I am for
foxy
are there more than 6 00 right it seems
like there's more than 16 around
seems like there's a lot more than 60
all right
damn I'm good God damn I'm good I've
been practicing harder than you've ever
practiced anything in your life I don't
care if you're a master pianist if
you're an Olympic pole vaulter you have
not practiced as hard as I have
practiced to beat this I will broke no
argument Brooke I'll Brook no argument
what oh frick
oh frick wait a minute I'm getting boxed
in here
getting [__]
this is no laughing matter
this is serious
which way are you gonna approach me
perfect
perfection
Perfection 8 of 16. I'm halfway there
[Music]
because I
I'm a master
this would be a terrible idea to do this
I'm doing it because I'm so bold
oh for it it's a bad idea oh so bad so
bad idea so bad idea so bad idea
oh genius idea
oh no bad idea
oh I don't want to roll it back I can't
escalator row anymore oh
hit the music cut the lights
in a world wait no stop rollback
we're all your dreams come true
[Music]
experience
I'm gonna
open tablet there's a tablet I'm gonna
play this on easy tablet I have a wrench
um this is a great update look at this
update guys
wow see
what the frick
All Right freeze them
pretty good I'm pretty good
that's not bad
that's pretty good oh it's a cool down
foxy is rapidly approaching your
position
oh
what an idiot what an idiot
what a dummy what a dummy
freaking idiot over here
oh wait wait
idiot
dummy oh wait
wait a minute bad bad idea
wait hold on free
no hey you little sad oh did you get a
little bit Frozen in place oh are you a
little bit depressed
after me now okay what an idiot I'm a
genius see this job I've been practicing
a lot in the interim between the last
time that you saw me and the now
I've been practicing non-stop endlessly
actually just waiting for my opportunity
to be able to play this for you Bonnie
are you there
yeah I'm looking at you
not so much Bonnie anymore so it's a
penis body I'm gonna get demonetized
hey shut up me it actually is extremely
useful to be able to see their positions
even if I weren't able to freeze them
having that listed in front of me is uh
impeccable where am I whoa
I don't know this bridge very well
foxy is rapidly approaching my position
I'm gonna freeze foxy
I think Bonnie just activated where am I
I'm gonna be in trouble because I I
shouldn't oh well oh frick
oh oh God oh my God don't come this way
oh god oh oh oh that's a problem freeze
God he was floating in midair
ominously okay Okay so
so he is
seems to be right around the corner here
which is a problem
he's not approaching much he's
approaching my position he's not
approaching my position he turned around
he's a dummy he's a dummy
he's dumb he's dumb he's very dumb
I shouldn't have insulted him uh except
for the fact that I'm gonna freeze him
in place get froze Oh no you're so sad
too bad shut up I hate you nine of 16.
already done
that one already done
oh nice
I'm gonna ring around the rosium maybe
not because I don't know which way he's
going to go my pockets are full of
posies
I'm posing
oh frick
I'm posing I've posied
oh God I'm just gonna do it I'm so brave
I'm so brave
man this freezing mechanic is really
clutch
oh well that's oh wait a minute don't
kill me ah
it's fine
okay
well I've got 11 of 16 and he does seem
like there are exactly 16 belts which is
unfortunate for me
but that being said
oh God no no no no no
have I done all these inner ones I feel
like I'm missing
just obvious ones that are on the main
circuitious path
but I might be wrong about that I think
I'm definitely missing three of them
right along here
so that's good
prostrat on my freezing place oh my God
oh my God oh yes
he's rapidly approaching my position
he's rap I'm detected I have been
detected I'm detected currently
currently am detected two valves left
two valves two valves two valves left
oh you're a problem yeah you go that way
you go that way idiot gummy dumbass
dummy he's dumb he's dumb he's big dumb
okay this is one of two left and I think
the other one just has to be
right around the corner somewhere else
foxy don't come this way he's coming
this way oh that was a bad time to
freeze
I'm the best
I'm the greatest I'm the greatest please
tell me I don't have to like Escape
afterwards or something like that uh
that's not it that's not it
is this one hit would this be it is
oh yeah oh yeah
oh that's it
I've done it
freeze freeze
I've got active yes
yes I uh but there's another part games
since last win I how do you know I've
played 14 times screw you it's the first
time but do you want the true ending
yes let's roll it back one more time
welcome back to Locked In sewer I know
what you want you
need the truth
lies in the hard mode of this game and
dear God I hope that I can yes tablet is
up
oh God
papa needs ah shut up me I need a
thumbnail screenshot
you're gonna give it to me you're gonna
give me what I want wow what does make
it hard
hey shut up go away
yeah what hey wait a minute where's the
wrench
there it is okay
good to go let's do this
that's a problem detected what do you
mean detected what do you mean detected
what do you mean deducted the what do
you mean
don't do that
I definitely should get all the ones in
here first because Bonnie does become a
problem almost immediately
okay Bonnie seems to be active is Bonnie
active Maybe
maybe Bonnie's active
oh yeah Bonnie's active
all right Bonnie
freeze Bonnie
so supposedly
I say supposedly with big supposedly
at some point here
we're gonna have a special guest
a new surprise
to tantalize us
oh
it's a problem
that was good instincts of mine that was
very good instincts of mine to turn
around only with years and years of
practice
oh you please stop
okay
I got that one I've done that oh where
am I
tell me he's not right there okay good
we're doing good
we're doing
what
how did my hair get like that it's like
I got struck by lightning I think we got
golden Freddy
what's that
the bite
of locked and Sewer all right I gotta I
gotta end it there guys I'm too scared
I'm going this game is too real it's
actually good I I have no problem with
it and I do appreciate that the
developer updated it also you know I I
don't mean to like Razz on anyone else I
don't really care I'm just playing games
for fun and that's what it's all about
so it cheers to you it's not me thank
you so much for watching let me know
what you thought down in the comments
below
and uh watch out for golden Freddy in
those sewers cause man he is there and
as always
I'll see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]